welcome to google cloud drawing board
where we doodle our way through the
cloud
today's topic what is cloud operations
this video is divided into chapters
watch the full video or skip ahead to
any section of your choice
you know the time when you want to see
how your cloud deployment is behaving or
if something's broken in production and
your users might be impacted
you are scrambling because there are too
many tools to look through
to find and resolve the issue that's
where cloud operations comes in
it's a suite of products to monitor
troubleshoot and operate your services
at scale enabling your devops sres or it
operations teams to utilize the google's
sre best practices
it offers integrated capabilities for
monitoring
logging and advanced observability
services like trace
debugger and profiler the end-to-end
operations suite
includes capturing signals monitoring
systems
managing incidents troubleshooting
issues with
built-in telemetry out of the box
dashboards recommendations
and more so let's see how does cloud
operations
work first cloud logging which is a
fully managed and highly scalable
service that aggregates
log data from all your infrastructure
and applications into a single location
it collects the log data from google
cloud services automatically
and you can feed custom logs through
cloud logging agent
open source fluentd or the api it gives
you
complete control to decide how and where
to store these logs
including keeping them in cloud logging
exporting to cloud storage for archival
bigquery for analytics or streaming them
via cloud pub sub
to a third party destination log viewer
gives you
powerful capabilities to filter the logs
convert them to log based metrics for
monitoring alerting
analyzing and visualizing cloud
monitoring provides observability across
your apps and infrastructure regardless
of where it is
google cloud on-prem or in other clouds
it supports a variety of metrics
integrations and allows you to define
custom metrics unique to your use case
and even send those metrics to external
systems
using the metrics explorer and
monitoring query language
you can analyze these metrics on the fly
identifying correlations
and easily add the corresponding charts
to a dashboard
you can use out of the box or custom
build dashboards to get a consolidated
view of the health of your
infrastructure
service or application and easily spot
anomalies
but we know that you cannot sit around
all day looking at dashboards
so cloud monitoring provides alerting
where you can create policies to alert
on performance metrics
uptime checks and service level
indicators
now let's focus our attention on
advanced observability
feature trace trace provides
visualization and analysis to understand
request flow service topology and
latency issues in your app
debugger allows you to inspect the state
of running applications
after deployment without needing to stop
or slow it down
profiler continuously analyzes your
code's performance on
each service so that you can improve its
speed and reduce your cost
and it is designed to run in production
with effectively no performance
impact while trace is used to track
relationships and latency between
services profiler tracks this across the
individual functions in your code base
and debugger helps find root cause from
method
to the specific problematic piece of
code now you can use the cloud console
or the api to use cloud operations tools
all these tools offer a very generous
free tier to make it easy for you to get
started
from the security perspective all your
data is encrypted at rest and in transit
your security focused audit logs are
automatically available in cloud logging
telling you
who did what where and when and with
access transparency
you can always stay in compliance
because it captures the actions google
personnel
takes while offering you support i bet
that keeping your applications up and
running
and making sure your customers are happy
is your number one priority
and cloud operations helps you do just
that
by using service level objectives that
work across
all application types and cloud
environments or using error reporting to
identify bugs in your applications
cloud operations provides your ops teams
with the out-of-the-box observability to
monitor your infrastructure
and your applications wanna get started
check out the free trial
you